la première visite officielle d'un chef
d'État français en Corée du Sud a été
marqué ce matin par un incident franç
mitteron a en effet été victime d'un
malaise à l'issue d'une cérémonie
d'accueil sous un soleil tropical
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
Philippe arward Yv
Barb rue de journée pour le président
mitteran qui s'achève par un dîner
officiel offert par le chef de l'État
coréen kimyungang où tout va pour le
mieux 5h plus tôt François miteran est
victime d'un malaise lors de la
cérémonie d'accueil à la maison bleue la
résidence du président coréen 14h de vol
sans escale 7h de décalage une chaleur
moite 28°gr et des œufs mangés
auparavant seraiit la cause de cette
indisposition prix d'un vomissement le
président doit interrompre son
programme il a dû se se retirer pendant
5 minutes il n'a pas subi de soins
particuliers il s'est contenté de boire
un verre d'eau comme ça lui est déjà
arrivé en d'autres circonstances
retour aux affaires Alain Jupé s'informe
de la santé de François mitteran qui
leur ass les entretiens avec les
dirigeants coréens commencent avec 30
minutes de retard et portent sur les
dossiers économiques industriels la
France ayant fait une percée en Corée
grâce au TGV espère bien décrocher
d'autres
contrats après les discussions François
mitteran est sin comment vous allez vous
allez mieuxqu pourcient qui n est arrivé
l'entourage présidentiel confirme encore
ce soir que le programme se déroulera
normalement aussi bien en Corée qu'au
Kazakhstan où monsieur miteran est
attendu jeudi malgré l'épidémie de
choléra qui s'estvit dans ce pays le
porte-parole